hi everyone this is Miguel concepción
editor gamespot here with Matt s Pinelli
associate editor GameSpot here to talk
about metal gear survive the other day
we went to a preview event where we got
to check out mostly the initial chapters
of the single-player mode plus a little
bit of the multiplayer Matt what are
your initial thoughts of the game well
straight off I was actually kind of
surprised I mean I know that Allah
there's been a lot of sort of reluctance
with this game ever since it was
announced people were kind of hating on
it and my overall experience coming out
of it was actually kind of fun it's it
it's a survival game through and through
right I think it really lives up to the
survive name I think we were talking
about how it draws these parallels with
other games like dayz and state of decay
where you're spending so much time just
drinking water and eating and there's
this interesting another variable you
have to consider this game because you
know even though you are not swimming or
anything you actually have to watch your
oxygen great that that was what I found
to be in a completely really like
interesting and different thing about
the way this game functions in terms of
as a Metal Gear game because you meet
Metal Gear has always been very
traditionally about stealth so to have
things like manhandling an auction
getting oxygen gauge which you primarily
do when you go into link which is
basically called to dust which is this
foggy area in the map it makes it
interesting because you actually have to
it really focuses in on managing all
these different meters in the way that
you're moving and the way you're
traversing the environment sneaking past
enemies which is not something you've
had to worry about in previous Metal
Gear games too much right it's very
jarring I mean even though it's it's
really great to actually finally play a
Metal Gear game using the phantom pain
and
it's definitely not like phantom pain -
I mean you are it sort of brings us
contrast to how much of a superhuman
snake was the fact that he had this
unlimited stamina phantom pain and now
your stamina is severely limited and you
got to manage it by constantly you know
sustaining yourself it was a lot to
juggle I don't know if in the long term
it's gonna translate to actual fun in
the long run right yeah that that all
comes down to how plentiful sort of
resources are and how manageable it
makes the game makes it for you to like
gather things I noticed when we were
playing like the way you even like hunt
for food right is that the and the map
they have these little like side
missions and side ops that'll open up
just like in phantom pain or you can
just go there and hunt down hunt animals
and stuff but those don't didn't seem to
appear very often maybe there's like one
or two every like mission or so like it
was very specific this is the point
where you have to go to hunt and it
seemed like you finding resources and
stuff are you finding like things like
food which are like is essential to your
survival in this game was it wasn't as
easy as finding like normal crafting
resources right I mean after playing
about three hours of the single-player I
was assured by Konami that all these
areas where you actually found the
animals they would eventually respawn
but I was actually I actually ended up
hitting a wall because I would like to
think the first area where ended up
getting animals would be the first place
where you would actually they would
actually respond and that didn't happen
so I was kind of just waiting and it's
kind of fiddling around in the home base
and just waiting for our multiplayer
sessions to start which we'll get to
later yeah and speaking of the home base
that's actually where you end up doing
all the crafting and just like surviving
there is a lot of crafting yeah you have
to do yeah I mean that's the basis of
what you're doing in the game really
like you're you're like any old survival
game you're you're making constant runs
into the environment to go explored
literally just try to find whatever you
can
like you'll you'll go into these like
abandoned bases and like fine like bags
of cotton or metals and all that stuff
that which you can use to yeah to make
clothes weapons back at your home base
essentially I mean I suspect this give
me one of those games where you're gonna
spend like the first five hours just
getting the hang of things
figuring out where what you need in the
story I suspect a lot of people are
gonna want to like start all over again
because you don't know if it's more
important to prioritize crafting a gun
versus crafting a kettle I mean the I
should add that the water that you first
get in the game is dirty and will get
sick and you will need certain types of
medication but apparently if you do
magic craft a kettle you could purify
the water right right so you gotta be
meticulous and it'll be interesting to
see how how what people what players and
fans will prioritize when you know they
get all these crafting materials so
another thing that we definitely had a
chance to try out it's also to combat
just like the limited stamina you are
not as skilled as snake in CQC in fact
when fighting off some of these zombies
do CQC you know me you know well I'm
married getting grabbed by some zombies
and just being able to shake them off
and I noticed that there were some CQC
style animations but you definitely
didn't have the whole like suite of like
combo moves that snake had apparently I
mean this obviously feeds into the skill
tree and it seems like the game dangles
this carrot that potentially as you
level up you could potentially be as
good as snake near the end the game
right right bill you have to kind of
wonder how like I wonder how much how
persistent like sort of all these like
meters you've to handle or manage or I
wonder how much is going to be sort of
still a problem as you're becoming more
like I like sure you can pull off this
stuff but like at what cost still like
how is that gonna work out right and but
I mean the game will give you a lot of
incentives to actually confront the
zombies because one of your the currency
for levelling up is this crystal this
rock called kuba kuba yeah right and you
get coupon for killing zombies and
they're actually a lot of it seems like
the game lends to all these
opportunities to quote-unquote harvest
some B's you can get their attention and
if you have the right parts you could
craft and build these fences from
scratch and I guess you could funnel the
zombies toward you and use your initial
weapons like your staff or your machete
to sort of keep them at bay and you know
kill them in droves provided that you're
you know you have enough fences to build
yeah there were a few scenarios in which
that seemed obviously because of the
zombies and stuff there are a lot of
comments and areas in the game where you
usually will get rushed by a like a
whole pack of them and the game will
often challenge you to like have to be
very meticulous of how even like set
forth that right now I'm plan that ahead
because like you see a group of zombies
you know that you're not gonna be able
to like avoid them using stealth like
you'll it'll became often like sort of
prepare you to be like okay like how can
I like get these zombies to come in
through this like little small pathway
should I set up a fence here how many
layers offenses should I like set up and
do I have enough strengthen the spirits
like take them all out cuz like that
mance is gonna go down cuz there's a
whole bunch of beat zombies were there
so yeah that was something that was
interesting about like I don't know like
the comment is we weren't able to see a
whole lot of diversity in it but from
what was there it was speaking of lack
of diversity and and the fact that we
had to go into these zombie infested
areas a lot of the story involved having
to go and find these these computer like
these panels
yeah the motherboards yeah you wait to
find these motherboards
and we find out that these motherboards
feed into this AI that teaches us a
little bit more
about the crafting and other things you
can do in the game and we were told that
we start on the third chapter of the
game and we continue in the fourth
chapter which is kind of odd that
there's so much onboarding still yeah
this deep into the game I'm not sure if
that's really will speak to the overall
quality game but it did seem like I was
really doing chores more than you know
engaging you know mission assignments
yeah totally just from the start like
there just wasn't a whole lot of things
that were different in terms of the way
like the kinds of mission objectives
you're doing and and the kind of combat
you were doing and I only hope that you
know once you start crafting more tools
like different kinds of bombs and
weapons and whatever kind of fence is
that you'll get access to that the game
will start opening up in terms of being
a little more creative in the way that
like you know like supply phantom pain
was right off the bat where it offered
you so many different solutions and all
this crafting relates to the fact that
we recently learned that Metal Gear
survive actually has to be online all
the time despite that you might be
spending most your time playing the
story we actually did play a little bit
of the multiplayer mode at least out of
the box it's a PvE co-op mode where you
have to defend yourself against multiple
waves of zombies yeah yeah and I was at
you you drop me draw sort of comparisons
to fortnight which kind of from what I
gather actually is very very similar we
only had so much time to sort of level
of our characters and stuff so when we
actually jumped into a session we were
kind of under level yeah the session
didn't last too long but we did get a
little feel for being able to build
fences and fortify our location so it
seems to have a lot of long-term
potential yeah provided that you know
what level the zombies are in relation
to yours we actually did a little bit
more fun in the lobby because pretty
much the only part of Metal Gear survive
where you have unlimited ammo yeah why
did you have a gun yeah exactly a lot of
goofy high jinks to say the least that
was just setting up fences I give them
limited defenses and anything alright
it's so like I was just like trying to
box people off and there's a dude who
was just shooting me forever and we're
all jumped like diving into one another
trying to like stagger yeah what's
actually surprisingly funny but going
back to the single player you also want
to talk about how the the map you found
it fun to explore yeah like I one of the
things the way the game works is like
you have a home base right so like the
way it challenged you to like you know
you have to get resources so you have to
kind of adventure off into whatever
direction to look for them either from
you know you being guided there through
an objective you have to accomplish or
just you doing so from your own free
will and what I liked about that is that
when you're exploring the map itself
isn't filled out so you're just kind of
moving about trying to find what got
going whatever direction really the
interesting thing is like when you come
back and you kind of register sort of
your progress with the home base they'll
start filling in the map on your idroid
and what I found interesting about that
is that it really encouraged this
initiative to want to explore and I
found that fun and engaging to be able
to just kind of seeing a little bit of
the paths I'm taking and kind of seeing
just like oh maybe if I if I just got to
this little section of the map meme I
might have found something so that
that's something that the game manages
to do well which you know to be honest
survival games have a kind of a tendency
to encourage that kind of desire to do
that and anyway but I think in this game
it works pretty well in the way that it
kind of the map will reveal itself only
when you return and sort of keeps like
so the teasing of this idea of like oh
what's over there what's over there what
can I find over
so I will admit that you know going into
the fog it was it was such a contrast to
not be able to actually see see where
you're going because the map does not
reveal what's in the fog yeah but I
actually eventually got used to it and
they just give you just enough visual
information to at least know how to get
out with the little blinking sort of I
guess tower or beacon right right yeah
like even when you're in the fog like if
you get far enough it even doesn't even
like because when you're looking at your
eye droid map you'll see where your
location is on the map for the most part
but once you get too deep into the fog
like you won't even see it so you are
kind of blind you have to like yeah you
have to look at the light in order to
kind of figure out where to go so
personally overall I'm on the fence on
metal gear survive but I am glad that
the game actually uses the phantom pain
engine its phantom pain was one of my
favourite games of the last five years
and it's just refreshing and despite the
fact it's not a Hideo Kojima production
that we're actually getting to
experience another Metal Gear game using
this engine overall like I came out I
came away from metal ger survive feeling
pretty optimistic I'm kind of hoping
that it'll be fun it's decently fun
survival game my only concern is that
from my time it really feel Metal Gear
enough in the terms of it like if it's
story didn't seem to justify its use of
the name yet for my time of it and also
stealth kind of felt like there was a
little consequence to whenever you were
sneaking past like zombies and stuff if
you got caught and you ran away they
were something they wouldn't chase you
so like I don't know these little things
in Metal Gear that really I hold
important they were a couple things that
didn't really get and get to me my time
playing but still I am I do want to go
back and play more well ok Matt thanks a
lot for your time and thanks for
watching
you